well i am delighted to have this
opportunity for this conversation with
all of you and i want to begin by
thanking johannes for being willing to
moderate
this event for us and also
to the black diamond which i
saw as i was taking a short boat trip
and went by and
marveled at it and
i'm looking forward to
this opportunity now someone asked me
why if you're here in
denmark and then you're going on to
norway and sweden and then later in the
month you'll be at fin in finland
why would you
take time to have this discussion with
young danes and i think the answer is
very obvious to me
and that is because as johannes just
said i spend all of my time trying to
figure out how we're going to give to
you to
my daughter to the young people that i
work with every day
the opportunity
for the best kind of future
possible
and it's always different wherever i am
in the world i can speak with young
people in indonesia or in february i was
in tunisia
today here in copenhagen but
there's a common theme and it perhaps is
more pronounced because of the
connectivity of the world that
we are all living in that didn't exist
certainly when i was your age or even a
decade ago to the extent it does today
so there are commonalities
that young people themselves are feeling
and seeing
that might never have been apparent
in the past
but it's especially important for me as
i start here in denmark and then
go on to the north to say thank you
because
the governments and people of your
country and the other three
that i will be visiting
have been such extraordinary
stalwart advocates for
democracy for economic opportunity for
inclusive
growth
you are among the world's most
generous people
and i have seen the results of that
generosity firsthand
i've also seen the
extraordinary skill of the danish
military
over the skies in libya on the ground in
afghanistan i watch with great
admiration your leadership on climate
change and clean energy and later today
i'll have a chance
with your prime minister to announce a
new partnership where the united states
and denmark will try
uh to do even more to promote
green technology
but i also have a personal uh
relationship because in washington i
live across the street from the danish
embassy and ambassador's residence
and i can attest from my daily
experience that danes are terrific
neighbors
and that
no matter what the season might be i see
the young danes who work at the embassy
uh riding their bicycles uphill
i've seen it in snowstorms i've seen it
in driving rainstorms it always makes me
embarrassed that i'm not out there with
you um so it's truly a sight to behold
um but it also is a reminder of the
energy that emanates from this important
albeit uh small country
so what could we think of and
as we move into this conversation
how can we better use
technology today
to make sure that you and
people like you
whether they're in advanced economies in
the west
whether they're in rising economies or
in
emerging ones
have an opportunity to fulfill your own
potential
expectations seem to be rising at a time
when opportunities are dwindling
when i met in tunisia with a group of
young people
i was struck by how much they expected
now that
they were free
and i knew
how difficult it would be
and can we get opportunity moving
at the same pace as rising expectations
there is as you probably know a youth
bulge as it's called by demographers in
the world today
in many developing countries 60 of the
people are under the age of
30. and the obvious question is where
will the jobs come from
uh in europe of course
populations are getting older not
younger but this dynamic creates its own
challenges particularly for young people
because will you
have the kind of safety net that has
been
available to your parents
or not
so whether you live in the developing or
the developed world
uh the question i hear over and over
again from young people is what's my
future going to look like and what role
can you
who are in government today
or we who are on our way into uh our
lives uh do to ensure the right answers
i think there are a couple of things
first we need to recognize that uh youth
empowerment uh is a concept that has uh
arrived if there were ever any doubt
about it
years ago
in the 1960s which i
know sounds like ancient history i can
well remember
our own efforts to try to change the
direction of
a war to change the direction of a
society
and today
what i see is that young people need a
chance to be more involved in and more
empowered to be involved in the
decisions that affect them
secondly i think we have distinct
challenges that have to be addressed
as to how we come up with the economic
and political pathways
that will translate this concept of
empowerment
into a reality
that does require a level of
participation you know one of the most
distressing meetings that i've had over
the last year
was
with a group of the young
revolutionaries who led the revolution
in egypt
who started in tahrir square what became
an extraordinary historic
change
and i sat at a table with
about 20 of the leaders
and i asked them now that
you have a chance
to make the decisions about what
your political system will look like
what do you intend to do to become
organized politically
and their answers were we don't do
politics we do revolutions
and i said excuse me
you know i maybe i'm showing my age or
maybe i'm of a different era
but
i know that if you don't become involved
in the political life of your country
all that energy all those hopes
can dissipate
and now as we look at the outcome of a
free and fair election by all accounts
in egypt i'm hearing the voices of some
of the same people i met with who are
saying
how did this happen you know what
happened to our candidates what happened
to the people who were at the forefront
of the revolution
one of our famous american politicians
mario cuomo once said
you campaign in
poetry but you govern in prose
well that means to me that if you expect
to see the changes that can come
to provide that sense of empowerment and
participation
there has to be
participation politically and third we
have to look at what works and here in
denmark
historically
you have made it a priority to expand
economic opportunity to people on the
sidelines and
you have according to all of the
analysis the least
income inequality in the world
that is quite astonishing as i watch my
own country
grow in income inequality and it is an
important
goal
that all of us should be moving toward
to
prevent inequality from distorting
society from distorting
politics
and denmark is
not immune from the changes in the world
economy but you have certainly navigated
them
more successfully than many and let me
just close by saying a few words about
the current crisis in europe
obviously it is for europeans to
determine the way forward whether you
are
in the eu and or in the eurozone the
european project deserves
support in our view
and i know that in hard times uh people
can be
uh led to hunker down or even build
walls uh to
go back to the old divisions that so for
so long bedevilled uh europe
but the values underlying the european
project are still true today the belief
that a countries and a people's strength
depends in part on whether your
neighbors are strong and prosperous that
the best way for people to get ahead is
through partnership with one another
rather than at each other's expense
whether you are danish or italian
latvian or spanish there should be a
place for you in the european community
and the dream of a europe in which all
people from all backgrounds live
and work in dignity and peace is what
inspired
generations that came before you to
persist in the european project
so i know that there are some challenges
that we all face
i'm certainly aware of the ones that my
country is facing
but i am confident that the values that
we have in common
uh and the aspirations uh that uh are
shared
uh not only by danes and americans but
increasingly by people everywhere
can be given
the reality that we all deserve
but only if
there is a level of political
participation
by young people so
i say the same thing whether i'm in
cairo or copenhagen
get in the game dare to compete
be part of charting the new future that
is waiting to be born
and the united states will
be very
proud and happy to make that journey
with you thank you all very much
thank you so much madam secretary and
once again welcome to denmark i hope
really that you are enjoying your stay
here so far are you i am and this is
my fourth time in denmark and
i always
feel as i was saying to you in the
hallway that i want to stay longer and
see more so
i'm looking forward to coming back as a
private citizen because i've always been
here
you know on an official visit and that
is not quite as free now my husband who
was here about a week ago
who is now as he likes to say retired
had the most marvelous time walking the
city going to uh tivoli gardens going
out to dinner and i must say i was a
little jealous so
we've we've promised each other we'll
come back
uh when we're both retired
i hope that you're comfortable in this
chair actually i just want to tell you a
short story about it it's you might
recognize it it's the same chair as
um john f kennedy said in in the
memorable tv debate in 1960 when he was
debating with the vice president nixon
so it's kind of iconic for for danish
design and um
i would this is a commercial break right
yeah this is good this is good
danish design is you know among my
favorites so now that i'm sitting in the
same chair john kennedy said and i have
to sit up straight
a great chair for a great person i i
would like to start out by asking you a
question about denmark actually
um when you travel around the globe as a
dane you're often met with oh denmark
isn't that the capital in norway or
you have polar bears walking around in
the streets i know that you know our
country you've been here but
honestly madam secretary
what do you think when i say denmark
i think of
progress
strength accomplishment
because i've seen it i've seen it
over
several decades now
and
the leadership that denmark has shown in
humanitarian and security and technology
and design and
social organization and political
stability
and democratic
sustainability
is you know very uh admirable and it's
something that
i really look to
because of course you're a small country
but if you add
up all that denmark has contributed
it's quite a remarkable uh history
i would like to ask you as the u.s
secretary of state um
what is your greatest concern right now
well you know the
they are interlocking um
always the greatest concern when you're
in
a position like this is
uh the fear
that uh
there can be nuclear proliferation
and either by in a rogue state or by a
non-state actor
we know that a lot of the
extremist terrorist groups keep seeking
weapons of mass destruction not only
nuclear and radiological material but
chemical and biological
and that is deeply
uh distressing
at the same time we see old-fashioned
conventional
military means being used against
innocent people
as we just saw horrifically
again in
syria so it's both the new threats that
are part of our modern age and the
age-old
problems of
dictatorships and brutality and human
rights abuses
and in the world we find ourselves in
because of technology we now know what's
happening everywhere i don't think we
have the capacity to act everywhere
which makes it very challenging because
when you know that people are being
murdered in the
eastern congo
or syria or
being having their human rights abused
anywhere in the world
there's the natural tendency of wanting
to do something so
we have to be as effective as we can
against the threats that we see
before
opening up for questions from you guys i
just want to ask you one more question
you mentioned syria yes
recently we saw some horrific pictures
coming out of the city of hula
more than a hundred persons brutally
slaughtered
when is the u.s going to say enough is
enough now we really have to use
military force to stop these killings
well one of our
great
dilemmas
is that
you know
the action that we took part in in libya
that denmark was a key
partner in
had the united nations support so
thereby you had the international
support
and
we do not yet have that
we have very strong
opposition from russia and china but
it's primarily russia
and that makes it
harder to put together an international
coalition
i've not in by any means given up on it
because i think every day that goes by
makes the case stronger and
i talked with um special envoy kofi
annan yesterday actually on on the
flight over
uh because
he is
you know working hard to expand his
mandate to be able to do more to push
the assad regime
in order to accomplish that we have to
bring the russians on board
because
the dangers we face are
terrible
the continuing
slaughter of innocent people both by the
military and by
militias supported by the government and
then increasingly
uh by the opposition which is
understandably trying to defend itself
and
and kill
those who are trying to kill them
which could morph into a civil war in a
country that would be
uh riven by sectarian divides which
could then morph into a proxy war
in the region because remember you have
iran
deeply embedded in syria
their military
are coaching the syrian military
their
so-called goods force which is a branch
of the military is helping them set up
these militias these sectarian militias
and you have russia continuing to supply
them arms and you have turkey very
worried on the border and you have
jordania are jordan and the jordanian
government worried and so
we know it could actually get much worse
than it is
and we're trying to prevent that and my
argument to the russians is they keep
telling me
they don't want to see a civil war and i
have been telling them their policy is
going to help contribute to a civil war
so
it's not a satisfactory answer yet but
we're trying to keep pushing all the
pieces together to support kofi annan
as a an independent voice because the
syrians are not going to listen to us
they will listen maybe to the russians
so we have to keep pushing them